[Music]
let's go to bridgette in finley ohio hey
bridget what's up
hi dr jen how are you
i'm excited to talk to you today i am
more excited to talk to you freezing
and freezing because we got like four to
six inches of snow it was a snow day so
my kids have been home all day
you have that voice of a mom who's
almost at the end of her snow day rope
good for you honestly hiding in my car
right now yeah
i love it
i love it so hey so what's up how can i
help
so my husband has a new job and we are
going to be relocating this summer um so
we are wondering how and when we should
tell our kid where are you going
um two hours south to cincinnati
all right so how old are your kids
um seven so he'll be going into second
grade and then four going into
kindergarten um and then we have a six
month old so he's along for the ride
yeah yeah
so tell me what your concerns are
um
i think
i lived in the same town my whole life
though it's hard for me to relate to how
i'm going to
tell my kids that we're moving
the kindergartner
he
will
i mean be starting a new school so
either way i think
it's not going to be as hard as an
adjustment
where the seven-year-old
is already you know going into second
grade he has his friends he's been in
soccer
um
we also
just built a house like a year and a
half ago so this was supposed to be that
forever home
and so now it's not
um so i think that's
the
i guess hesitation and and selling it
for them because they have to
start over and i think
for both of us as parents like
um starting over as well neither of us
are super familiar with the area um
so how honest do you want me to be with
you
all the way
are
are you positive all right i'm gonna
give you i'm gonna give you
um two things
one is something i just i just i just i
have a whole chapter about this in a new
book
and the second is
um my honest take i think you're the one
struggling
and i think you're struggling because
you've never done this before because
it's hard because you've got a community
and because you've got connections there
and you had a picture
of what their life was going to look
like and now your picture has changed
and it's very very hard
when we are struggling to look in the
mirror and say this is my challenge
because it might be right is it right
that y'all are moving you feel good
about the move
so when we talked about
my husband getting the job he's kind of
head hunted
and this is like his career passion
and the company he worked for
said we don't want you to do that
anymore so he left and i 100 support
that because having a passion for your
job is awesome sure um and so then
this other company is saying we want you
to do this and we want to make you like
a director which is a huge bump that's
such a big deal
um i never wanted to live here in the
first place i
followed my husband because that's where
his job was and i can work anywhere in
the state working remotely
and
the location we've looked at the schools
we've got it like narrowed down we're
big into
having diversity and great in education
and
all the things like a target even 10
minutes from my house amazing so in the
long run we know this is best for our
family
but you're correct like the community of
people we found our church our friends
our neighbors
that's what i think we're struggling
with and because my kids have that too
that's where i know that
i think they'll struggle and so
all of us starting over i think
we're not we can get past that i'm just
trying to figure out how to verbalize
that to our kids
so the greatest gift
literally the greatest gift you could
give your kids especially your
seven-year-old
somewhat your kindergartner
is to let them know
this is hard
and that
it's the right thing for our family and
we're excited and daddy's got a new job
and it's going to be this and it's going
to be that
and it's going to be so so hard
and mommy's really going to miss her
friends
the worst thing you could do would be to
tell not tell them that you're going to
miss your friend not let them see you
cry
not let them see you're frustrated when
you're trying to pack and deal with a
newborn all that stuff
because they're going to miss their
friends
they're not gonna like to pack up their
room
and they're gonna feel like they're the
only one having these feelings and
they're gonna feel nuts
and so
i just did this i moved with a i guess
back when we moved it was eight and
seven or eight year old and then a three
year old i guess two or three year old
and
um
it was hard
and not so much
and i took uh we took our son on the
school visits and we took our daughter
as much as we could on her school visits
and
we
let them pick the restaurant when we
were driving around i mean right so we
invited them into the process as much as
we could
and it made the transition so smooth and
i said things like man i'm really gonna
miss such and such your friend
i love that they were your friend and
i'm really gonna miss them and their
daddy was my friend too i'm really gonna
miss him i let my kids know that i was
hurting
and in turn it didn't
make them scared it made them not feel
alone and not feel crazy
and then with like my hus it's obviously
my husband's job right
i guess not
not so much like the guilt but like
don't wanting them to like blame him
because it's see did you hear your
language they're not going yeah like you
are okay you are no you yes you are and
hey it's okay
it's all right
because it's the it's the right thing
for your family this is your words it's
the right thing for your family i'm glad
he's taking this job and it really
pisses me off we have to leave
those can all be true at the same time
yeah and he knows that but i think he he
specifically mentioned like he doesn't
want them to blame him and he has you
know why because he blames
himself putting things on to kids that
they're
either are going to be passing
they're going to be fleeting
or they're never going to enter their
mind
if you all tell them this is a new
adventure for our family we're going to
do this and there's a zoo in cincinnati
and we're gonna go to the zoo and
there's a
whatever in cincinnati we're gonna go
there like they'll be all in in 24 hours
or 48 hours
okay so the bribing with the pool
community is good of course it's good
you could take your kids your your
kindergartner to disneyland and if the
hotel you stay at has a pool they're
going to talk about that hotel we stayed
up with a pool for the rest of their
life right they're going to forget
disneyland they're going to remember
right so it's not about bribing it's
just about showing them hey there's cool
things here too
okay it's both and
what i don't want you to do is i don't
want your husband to feel guilty there's
gonna be that natural guilt i felt it
when i moved to nashville we moved for
my job to go work at a university
and it was the right thing it was good
everything about it was right all of it
and i still felt bad
because i was making my family have to i
mean
i wasn't making them do anything they
are coming along with me
their life was disrupted because of my
choice
and that guilt is okay
i don't ever want my family to be
inconvenienced or disrupted because of
me and they were
and that disruption was the right thing
to do it was great it's both in
and just like i said you can be all 100
on board my husband's going to make more
money he's going to be happier he's
going to be doing the things that he
loves which means he's going to love us
at the house it can be nicer to be
around
i can take the kids to cool places and
not just rando places and fin whatever
and
i hate that we're leaving i love the our
new house that we built together and
planned together and i love the schools
my kids are gonna go to and all those
things right it can be both and
and here's the second thing i set you up
okay
yeah um this so the first thing is is
your kid's gonna be fine you and your
husband have to be able to live in that
tension and you gotta tell your kids the
truth that you miss people too let them
see you guys grieving this transition it
will be
a great gift for them
the second thing here and i wrote about
it in this new book and it sounds like
i'm trying to pitch something or sell
something and i kind of am but here's
the thing yeah
we have a culture now that is obsessed
that revolves entirely around our
children
how are they feeling do they like me i
don't wanna i don't want them to to be
out of step a little bit i don't want
them to feel a little bit disconnected i
won't be out of place i don't want them
to i want them to like us
and
unwittingly
we have shifted the burden of our
families onto our kids
they're the epicenter
and our children cannot carry the weight
of our friendship of our feelings of our
regrets that's not their job their
shoulders aren't strong enough because
they're little kids
it's cruel to make them do that
the thing that they need desperately is
for us to model for them to make adult
decisions and to tell them this is what
we're doing because y'all are in our
family
you know what i'm saying
yeah yeah and often man we re-pattern
our lives around their schedules we
repound our lives around their
hearts and emotions and feelings now i'm
not saying you're like you're doing
you're doing gymnastics i don't care i
hate gymnastics daddy i don't care next
time i'm talking about you know what i
mean
yeah but i do mean in our house you're
gonna do one activity
you can be choir it can be knitting it
can be wrestling it can be jiu-jitsu it
you're going to do an activity
and preferably a mobility one we are all
moving as a family and because you're
seven you're moving with us and it is
going to be hard and it's good you hear
what i'm saying there i want your your
life to revolve around you and your
husband's decisions on what's best for
the future of your family
not about how our kids are going to feel
that makes sense
yeah yeah
so
do you feel
excited to move
yeah do you feel sad
yes
i'm sad that i'm losing like the
community that we've formed around us
so just having to recreate that
but i'm excited about all the things and
we've known this since
last july
so just as time is coming up it's like
getting more real and i'm a planner so
like
doing
all the planning for
for it and this has been something we've
been thinking about
like i said since we made that choice
that we were gonna have to move but
just not sure how to approach it so
let's let them in on the move too by the
way give them a box when you all start
packing and say go load up three things
and let them be a part of it and don't
even fix the box it's just going to be a
box of shenanigans
just tape it up and say way to go and
draw pictures on or whatever um your
seven-year-old let him let him or her a
part of the planning process the list
making process if you're a list maker
invite them into those things and
so when should we tell them because i
just don't want to take away from the
time that
you know he gets to enjoy but i don't
want to spring it on him either when are
you moving
after the school year's over that was my
stipulation with the new job is that
he's been working basically remote but
we knew we would need to move in the
next year so i said i wanted the kids to
finish out
this school year because i was about 38
weeks pregnant when he
got the job
so i would i would actually plan a trip
i would take him down to the zoo in
cincinnati
yeah and take the kids down there and
show them what a great town it is i
would do that
and not mention the move
maybe take them down there and take them
to a fun restaurant they're gonna have a
blast i'd let them have a good time in
there you're in your this is an
environmental move first
the the fear of the word move when you
call them in and say we have something
important to tell you
boom they're fully limbic they're not
listening to anything they're just
terrified
and so take them down and give them them
a picture in their mind of what this
could look like
and then in a couple of weeks say hey
daddy you know daddy got a new job
it looks like we're going to be moving
to that new town
and
remember the one with the zoo and we're
going to always point back to those
pictures
okay and then we don't have a house yet
have y'all found a house there yet
no we're in the looking process okay so
maybe let them say pointed a couple of
houses you like pull them up online and
let them point at a couple of them we
want ownership in this thing we want
participation never never never lie to
him okay
so don't say like oh we might be moving
no you know we are and so it will be
well looks like we're going to be moving
to this new community
we want you to help us
find a house and invite them in a little
bit and say mom and dad gets to make the
final call but which one do you think
you like the yard you know that you hear
what i'm saying
um do you want the one with a pool in
the neighborhood and let them yeah
that'd be great
um right so you're gonna invite him
along
always always always remembering
you you and your husband got to stay
connected in this deal i did not move
well it was a disaster
for uh my marriage did not move well
okay i had different expectations she
had different expectations and i did not
communicate well
disaster okay make sure y'all are
communicating every step of the way hold
that tension the whole way
the this is so the right thing to do and
i'm just gonna cry today and i think you
and your husband need to call that out
this is the right thing and i feel
guilty for moving us and disrupting
everything and taking us away from our
dream home
and i know this is the right thing and i
hate you for moving us i don't really
hate you i love you but i'm just
ah it's both and
and being honest with each other
together through this whole thing making
sure y'all stay
schedule time for intimacy and
connection in this time even though you
got a newborn it's hard with three kids
as it is three kids with a newborn and
moving oh my gosh oh my gosh stay
connected in this process stay connected
stay connected stay connected
and remember the world does not revolve
around your kids
revolves around y'all too and the life
you are building for everybody